[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
i begin by acknowledging the traditional
owners of the land on which we meet
i pay my respect to their elders past
present and emerging and on behalf of
the australian labour party i commit to
the uluru statement
[Applause]
and i say to my fellow australians
thank you for this extraordinary honour
[Music]
tonight the australian people have voted
for change
i am humbled by this victory
and i'm honored to be given the
opportunity to serve as the 31st prime
minister of australia
[Applause]
my labor team
will work every day
to bring australians together
and i will lead a government
worthy of the people of australia
a government as courageous and
hardworking
and caring as the australian people are
themselves
[Applause]
earlier tonight
scott morrison called me to congratulate
myself and the labor party
on our victory at the election
scott very graciously
wished me well
and i thanked him for that
and i wish him well
and
and i thank him
for the service that he has given to our
country as prime minister
i also want to acknowledge and thank
jenny morrison and their two daughters
for their contribution and sacrifice as
well
my fellow australians
it says a lot about our great country
that the son of a single mom who was a
disability pensioner
who grew up in public housing down the
road in camperdown
can stand before you tonight as
australia's prime minister